I'm I'm after yours oh my God I'm after
yours we should we should trade these
after the show Absolutely um well I'm
going to start with weight
congratulations new son right yes thank
you very much yeah 6 months old 6 months
oh are you sleeping more yeah like he's
doing okay he's sleeping more than we
are okay so you you have a two-year-old
right so so do you do Halloween do you
all get all done up I love Halloween as
someone who dresses up for a living um
it's not like my favorite thing to put
on a costume but of course like my
daughter really wanted us to do Frozen
yeah so um so she's Anna and I am going
to be Elsa and my partner's going to be
uh Kristoff and um so that's fun she has
no idea that Uncle Jonathan is Kristoff
yeah that'll be mindblowing when she
figures that out but oh my God yeah
she'd lose it it is funny when when
because my kids saw an animated thing
that I did and they were like it broke
the wall it was kind of intensely sad
yeah yeah they saw me in this movie
called ugly dolls and they were like we
don't understand but like and I was like
well you know like Elsa like you know
she's a real person and they were like
what and I was like oh my god oh no what
have I ruined I felt like a horrible
human but you know it's going to happen
soon or later I do that to kids on like
a regular basis when like it's like I'm
sorry you they're like you're old now
what
happened so that was what's so funny my
daughter was obsessed with Chris Martin
for like I mean years and she always
watched the yellow video but he's
younger he's like his first single and
so whenever she saw him she's like well
he looks different we age
[Music]
[Applause]
honey thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home